So now that we have seen
a two level page table,
let's see if we can work with
a four level page table.
This time let's assume we have
a 64 bit virtual address space.
A 64 kilobyte page size.
An eight byte page table entry.
And we have a relatively large program
that is only using addresses zero
through four gigabytes from
this huge address space.
The flat page table size is very large.
The question for you is it's
a power of two, what power of two?
So it's two to what?
And if you have a four level page
table where the page number is split
equally so the bits of the page
number are divided into
four equal groups to
access these page tables.
This page table uses
how many kB of memory?